she and your most recent project is
Alyssa portrait of a teen killer is that
the current name or has there been a
change well it's actually been a few
changes originally i called it column
line even though it's not about you know
Columbine and then we were shooting it i
called it the coal mine then I decided
after we're finished shooting the call
to call mine effect because basically
this actually goes into a story i forgot
about when I heard about Alyssa it was
getting them it reminded me of calm I I
stopped watching TV basically when call
might happen because uh there was some
trailer for a show about like I'm
one-hour special incall mind I saw where
it had the platoon music you know that
music from the two annoying women foes
like dying he throws his arms out you
know a very great cinematic moment in
music but they used that music with the
real footage of the kids running out
screaming while their friends are you
know getting shot to death and I just
thought that that was so sickening and
evil to like use real photos of these
kids being you know shot to death as
like a cinematic moment to get ratings
you know and so I stopped watching TV as
a teenager when I saw that I just was
like I'm done like it right there i just
stopped watching TV and just stuck to a
going into the theater or dvds you know
and i know no more television shows
because i want to see a trailer like I
just literally stopped watching TV shows
everything and when I heard about Alyssa
the way listen Bustamante the way that
they were glamorizing what happened like
it was a show it was specifically
milotic us I don't know because i tend
to cut so yeah yeah i was in the season
two really offensive but actually i was
like what an evil you know i just
was so disgusted by the what I saw you
know what she was saying you know about
Alyssa because I was thinking this is a
real person you don't even know she you
know he just found out about it you
don't even know she did it yet she
confessed but that could mean anything
because she's a kid and
I know based on being a kid myself that
police will try and beat you into a
false confession you know and so I was
just the kind of press it was getting I
just I was so reminded of Columbine I
did you know it just seemed so sickening
to sensationalize this stuff with kids
and use it for ratings and so because i
was reminded of Columbine I guess it was
more of a me title you know didn't make
sense anybody in necessarily but me so I
called it the call might affect but then
people thought i was using the titles to
sensationalize the film so kind of like
you know bad clashed on me and it wasn't
about Columbine some people thought I
was just trying to use the call my name
the seller thought I was like this exact
opposite of what I was trying to do so i
changed it to my name is a by anonymous
we were trying to think of a title I
think I came up with my name is a and
then Alicia the producer mentioned
something about a book called ask alice
oh yeah yeah I read it but something
about it being anonymous or by anonymous
or some pain and I'm like you know my
name is a by anonymous because i like
having titles were when you google it
only the movie comes up like amateur
porn circular you know that was the only
that had never been used before you know
that name and so my name is a I you know
googled it and I'll liked it's a
gazillion links to any time somebody
saying my name is a something it would
come up so I'm like how can we have this
be only the movies so we added the by
anonymous part and I thought it kind of
fit the ambiguity in a word ambiguity
yeah biggest nature vocabulary actually
isn't great um I thought that kind of
just fit um because the film is kind of
very it doesn't really follow this up
fall is a few characters and you're not
really sure of exactly what's going on
so I thought I kind of thought the
anonymous thing kind of fit um you know
with my name is a you know by anonymous
so anyway so we did that and then the
film circulated for so many years
because it was such a hard sell and we
finally found a distributor and then the
distributor you know it took a while to
get everything ready and figure out how
to market it and then finally just
recently after
you know it's been like almost five
years since we shot the movie now then
all of a sudden there was a name change
because the DVD is still called my name
is ava anonymous but the internet crowd
who has a short attention span doesn't
like to think or have any kind of you
know meaning than anything we're like
okay we have to have a title that's
going to grab you right off the bat and
it needs to start this is what I was
told it needs to start with like a
number or a letter a B or C because
people are too lazy when they're
watching when they're looking for a good
movie what's don't even get me started
on that but our generation the new
generation of you know the Internet
crowd is just too lazy to want to have
any kind of you know substance in
anything you know I was told so we need
to hit you something with like that's
like interface and starts with like an
ARB and since her name was Alisa that
actually worked out you know it all
worked out and I actually like the title
but that's the title for anything that's
not the DVD basically to answer that one
question her that long answer and that
question is a my name is a by anonymous
is DVD Alyssa a portrait of a teen
killer is everything else so
pay-per-view TV digital cable i don't
know i only watch dvds so all these
other outlets you know however people
watch movies these days that's going to
have the alyssa title
you